you
you
you
okay emcee
no i am not i think he's 6'2
[Music]
thank you thank you they got my lips and
everything else i'm good to go
all right
i want to wait around
thank you
um
so
okay
okay
about
what are you gonna do
can help you to see what you're doing
lose your focus okay that's a really
good idea
there's probably taken there just
whenever i open it
right okay that's a great idea
yeah i'll help you yeah you you help me
oh
okay
right there
that's all right
uh is
oh yeah
oh
you know what i'll go further down so
that will be the same distance from you
to your
right here
you know the light build button do you
have what is that is that party
this is
oh my goodness all right
well you forgot oh yo no way you use
nikon right
i do okay
like wheel because you can use your eyes
you can use one grinder
you can use the finder all right i got
it
it's beautiful and those already have
the white
i think i got it okay
i'm just predicting what he's going to
do you know
hey how are you you know what i did i
did not uh
tape it you did where where's the thing
i put it
okay now i will take it
what happens here are you talking about
like not one of the curved pieces the
straight piece that was already in there
the one that was in there last night not
good actually
enough to focus again i think i was too
much further back
okay yeah i have just moved up half step
so it's one bbc really tricky i'm using
part
six yeah better idea like you know
put it on 32 100
and then and then you can do
250 and f3 yeah yeah you want it
it's not true
yeah i like that better
okay okay check in here
oh you don't give me something can you
just do that
okay you got it
two chickens
yeah all right
i just got off the phone with them 10
minutes ago
you're looking tonight i print out a pdf
form
that puts everybody's name in there and
you're
going to make the league lauren's part
of the family she is
[Music]
um
i don't switch it on
do you want to put it again
right
how weird is that oh
[Music]
um
yes
can you do 8 p.m
[Music]
i wouldn't read it
thank you very much oh yes all right
right
the bench
confirmed 8 pm september 25th
um
right
see you all
[Music]
um
god
it's great
um
yes
look that up there
you gotta watch the twitter right before
my partner's rocking but it happened
before then
earlier you're right
something that's gonna be hard
we have another
[Music]
yes
is pre-debate focus group invite
that's important well i think that's
interesting that they are inviting
supporters to participate
it's probably like one of these things
for you
okay here we go
i mean i'm good
would you like to send it three dollars
now
[Music]
it's at 5
well
yes
it's hard
okay all right i think i got it
what do you think don't forget for your
one's in manual
yeah yeah
yeah i just put a herb i didn't get a
mess i didn't either
they're all like classic glass for
tissues
you don't have to wear outside
he said
this
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
wow
it's
yes
um
everybody
don't forget
oh
until yeah kind of work
all right
i
what was the last school
okay
oh damn
you just heard the jeans 5 15.
which means
i know six o'clock we have a dinner to
go to
you probably realized that yeah exactly
they changed it again changed it again 5
15. did you not get the memory
[Music]
concept of the power
well that's what happens when you drink
it
yes hey i'm just about to have a
presidential briefing can you come back
um okay
it's what you asked for
thank you
that is
i like it
yeah wake up
there you go
okay
uh
so
thank you very much everybody thank you
good afternoon hurricane sally made
landfall
as you know in alabama and florida last
night as
a category 2 hurricane and has caused 35
inches of rainfall in some places that's
a lot
we have hundreds of fema coast guard we
have the national guard personnel
on the ground assisting response to the
efforts and alabama is in great shape
and
every place that we are working with the
state governments
really in great shape we are uh
working very hard on that but it looks
like it's going to be
mostly safe but just follow the
instructions of all of your local
and federal people there we have the
best people
that you can have so i want to thank
everybody i want to thank everybody for
working so hard in florida
and they're very good at this the people
in florida handle it they know how to
handle it and the people working there
know how to handle it
the governors have all been spoken to
and
uh it's a combination of real spirit and
they have a tremendous esprit de corps
they have a tremendous
sense of working on hurricanes they've
gotten very good at it
and we've certainly had plenty even
since i've been here we've had a lot of
them so
that's in good shape hurricane sally uh
we're going to talk about big ten
football but that's a terrific
thing we'll discuss that at the end i
just want to go into the vaccine
distribution today my administration
released our detailed national vaccine
distribution plan
and that includes a plan to ensure that
we swiftly deliver the vaccine directly
to america's senior citizens
in nursing homes and it's all set we
have our military lined up
everybody's lined up and we think that's
going to go very nicely we're very close
to that vaccine
as you know and i think closer than most
people want to say or
certainly closer than most people
understand
to get the vaccine into the hands of
american people we're fully mobilizing
the awesome power of
american industry and also our military
this is the largest fastest and most
advanced vaccine distribution effort in
american history
by far i was reading where biden was
saying that
oh he's going to have a plan they did so
bad on swine flu you wouldn't even
believe it
take a look at their record on swine flu
in fact the person that headed it up
said it was a total disaster
we're on track to deliver and distribute
the vaccine
uh in a very very safe and effective
manner
we think we can start sometime in
october uh so as soon as it
is announced we'll be able to start
that'll be from mid-october on
it may be a little bit later than that
but we'll be all set so as soon as it's
given the go-ahead they're doing trials
as you know and as soon as it's given
they go ahead we will
get it out defeat the virus we've
manufactured all of the necessary
supplies so that as soon as the fda
approves the
vaccine and as you know we're very close
to that we'll be able to distribute at
least 100 million vaccine doses by the
end of
2020 and a large number much
sooner than that uh i'm calling on
biden to stop promoting his anti-vaccine
theories because all they're doing is
hurting the
importance of what we're doing and i
know that if
they were in this position they'd be
saying how wonderful it is
yeah they're recklessly endangering
lives you can't do that
and again this is really a case that
they're only talking to just started
talking a little bit negatively and
that's only because they know we have it
or we will soon have it and the answer
to that is
very soon the
case updates it's very interesting to
see what's happening because the test
positivity rate
is down among all age groups and has
fallen below
five percent for the first time since
this whole
nightmare of the china virus began
so it's fallen below five percent the
number of hospitalized patients has
decreased by 43 percent from mid july
43 nationally people
sick with the china virus now make up
only 1.5 percent
of all emergency room visits so we're
down to the lowest number we've had 1.5
percent of emergency room visits
is for the china virus and thanks to our
life-saving therapies and treatments
i think this is the best of all in terms
of our great percentages and all the
progress we've made
the fatality rate has fallen 85
since april 85 fatality rate
if you look at what we've done and all
of the lives that we've saved and i'm
going to ask that a
graph be put up and now it's up uh
this was right at the beginning this was
our prediction that if we do a really
good job
we'll be at about a hundred and a
hundred thousand to two hundred and
forty thousand deaths
and we're below that substantially and
we'll see what comes
out but that would be if we did the good
job if
the not so good job was done you'd be
between 1.5 million i remember these
numbers so well and 2.2 million
that's quite a difference so we're down
in this territory
and that's despite the fact that the
blue states had
had tremendous death rates if you take
the blue states out we're
uh at a level that i don't think anybody
in the world would be at
we're really at a very low level but
some of the states
they were blue states and blue state
managed and by the way we would
recommend they open up their states i
think it's very important that they
open up their states because if you look
at
certain of them north carolina
pennsylvania michigan
uh and a couple of others we have to get
those states open
it's hurting people it's hurting people
far more than the disease itself
so we would recommend that you open them
let your people have freedom
and it's unfair to your people to keep
them closed at this stage we know the
vaccine we know the
vaccines are coming but we know the
problem we understand who the vulnerable
are which is
primarily people with medical problems
but in particular
people with medical problems that are
older
so open up your states to facilitate
routine testing of the nursing home
residents
and staff we've delivered rapid testing
devices to all
one thousand four
oh it's busy um are we sure we're hung
up over
there
[Music]
okay
yeah i it's busy
i'll give it 60 seconds
it was a 10 to 90 minutes for the
president in a way he really hasn't
experienced
in
no
and to continue protecting our most
vulnerable which is
our senior citizens and we're going to
take good care of them
i want to congratulate big ten
football it's great it's back and i want
to
in particular i've been dealing with him
thank commissioner kevin warren
for the great job he did we've been
working with him
uh for a while there was a rumor being
spread that i didn't want football back
and was just the opposite that was
another disinformation rumor put out by
the biden campaign
and it was just the opposite but it
really spurred me into action
i called the commissioner a couple of
weeks ago and we started really
putting a lot of pressure on frankly
because there was no reason for it not
to come back and
kevin went and worked very hard i want
to thank the players the coaches for
working along and they wanted it very
badly the players and coaches in
particular the parents
also and big ten football just announced
as you know that their schedule they
announced the schedule and it's going to
be great
important to have i want to recommend
that the pac-12 also get going
because there's no reason why pac-12
shouldn't be playing now
and uh perhaps they'll start with at
least partially
i had recommended today to kevin and
others that maybe you want to start off
with 25
of the stadium or maybe you want to
start off with empty i don't know if
it's
i think they could have fans go frankly
but
they want to be careful they want to be
safe and they will be safe they've got a
very
good testing process for the players
coaches families etc
and so i just want to congratulate big
ten
it's gonna be great we're gonna love
watching that and again i wanna
recommend pac-12 you're the only one now
open up
open up pac-12 get going said the same
thing to big ten
and they did and now i'm saying it to
pac-12
you have time you really have time right
now get going
i want to thank all of those uh
wonderful coaches some of whom i spoke
with
and we went through a process over the
last
couple of weeks and i want to thank
congressman anthony gonzalez of ohio
who as you know was a great football
player some people know that i know that
but anthony was a great player great
receiver
went to the nfl also i want to thank tim
pataki of my staff he worked very hard
on this and he was up day and night
working with kevin and everybody else so
i want to thank tim pataki great job
so big 10 is back and it's going to have
hopefully a great season
the census recently found that in the
second quarter of 2020
hispanic americans home ownership
reached a record all-time high
that's all time in the history of our
country yesterday the census reported
that median income for americans
increased by an unprecedented four
thousand four hundred dollars
last year to a record of sixty eight
thousand seven hundred dollars
in 2019 income inequality fell for the
second straight year
the income gap widened under the obama
biden administration and it widened
fairly substantially and it narrowed
under the trump administration so
there's a little fact that you didn't
know so it narrowed under us and it
widened under obama
income grew more last year alone than
over the entire eight years of obama
biden
and uh that's a big statement but that's
the way it is in
2019 4.2 million americans were lifted
out of poverty
that's the largest poverty reduction
under any president
in history 4.2 million americans were
lifted out of poverty
the hispanic american poverty rate
reached the lowest level
ever history of our country hispanic
american poverty rate
lowest level ever i created the greatest
and fairest economy in history the
biggest gains went to
lower income americans as they measure
that kind of thing we
will be back to full strength very soon
we're going to have a fantastic year
next year it's looking like that i think
you're going to have a
incredible third quarter the numbers are
looking very very strong
for the third quarter we have numbers
that we're going to put out tomorrow
some of the individual things
car production housing production
housing ownership so many different
things are just
at levels that nobody thought possible
as we round the turn on the pandemic
the anti-police crusade
from the democrats and the radical left
and radical left democrats also has to
stop
the left-wing war on cops puts our
officers in
danger and our communities at very grave
risk
can't do this biden described the police
as the enemy
they're not the enemy they're the friend
they're our friend they're helping us
and if you go to i just saw a poll
just came out or recently came out where
african americans
by 84 percent wanted more police
they wanted safe neighborhoods in
phoenix last night a federal officer was
gunned down in a drive-by shooting
in la this weekend everybody saw that
this horrible human being or
whatever you might want to call him and
kim
they're looking all over they're trying
to find him
we're going to find out we're going to
get them but in la this weekend two
sheriffs
deputies were ambushed and viciously
shot
and they can never be the same they're
getting better but they can never be the
same i'll always stand by our heroes of
law enforcement
and we want to stop this horrible
rhetoric and stop it fast
i want to ask scott atlas to say a
couple of words
because i heard biden talking today
about
he wants to come up with a distribution
plan a distribution for the vaccine that
we came up with
a couple of things we came up with that
vaccine
it'll be announced fairly soon but
regardless this month next month
in a level of time that nobody thought
was possible because of what we did with
our fda
in terms of streamlining it i want to
thank thank dr hahn
but what we've done with the
streamlining has been incredible
and very safely number one is safety
number two is speed but
you can have perfect safety and have
much more speed and that's what we did
we did this
for more than the vaccine having to do
with the china viruses was
also for other things so many other
great drugs are out there that would
take
10 12 years to get them approved and
we've moved those schedules up
a lot but if this were
obama biden this would have taken two
three years before you were at a stage
where we are now
at so we're going to be very soon and
it's
sort of funny to watch uh joe biden
getting up and reading a teleprompter
and saying how
how he would have uh done this they had
h1 n1 he calls it the n1h1
it's h1n1 it's called the swine flu
and it was a disaster and as i said the
person that ran it for him said
the worst things about it i mean just
they didn't know what they were doing
they quit
they had they had no clue and that was
easy by comparison to this
there's the most contagious contagious
flu or virus that anybody seen this is
unbelievable how contagious it is you
found that out
but i watched biden quickly as he
discussed
without having without knowing a thing
about a distribution plan
and he said that we don't have a
distribution plan but
we do indeed our military we have
military we have everybody involved
it's uh it's a great plan
and it's a plan like no other and we can
start doing it
i believe the day that we come up with a
vaccine when it's
done we'll start that same day or the
day after
our military is very much involved and
they deploy troops they deploy these are
the generals that
that do logistics and all of those
things and we'll have it
all over the country and then ultimately
hopefully we'll be helping the world
with the
vaccine and it's very exciting but maybe
i'd ask scott atlas to come up and
describe a little bit about
that at the distribution plan in
particular because
biden acted as though there was no
distribution plan and we've been working
on this for months
and it's ready and scott has really
taken a hold of it and done an
incredible job
and uh please scott thank you
okay thank you thank you mr president
and
i didn't develop the plan i'm just
relaying information here
um but uh this is a plan that's a
57-page document that was sent to every
state today
and there's a uh different uh part of
this that was given to congress today
uh it was released by hhs it's on the
website
and in fact i thought it was covered
actually by the media so i don't think
it's a surprise but it's a comprehensive
plan
it's a public-private partnership to get
everything done in terms of logistics
the i.t
that's necessary to trace the first dose
because some of these
vaccines are anticipated to be two doses
there's tailoring of course by the
states and their specifics and there's
an administration of the vaccine plan
that will be done in over 51 000 outlets
including
for particular attention to minority
areas
over fourteen thousand uh federally
qualified
health centers and as the president just
said within the first 24 hours of
fda's approval under an emergency use
we will have vaccines being delivered
within the first 24 hours
uh and it will be done at virtually no
cost to americans
um and uh the terms of the uh
the dosage uh there will be and is it
anticipated
uh that no later than january all the
top priority
uh people will have received the vaccine
or be able to receive the vaccine
and so that kind of prioritization which
is the general prioritization done
for all vaccines that are developed
particularly in a pandemic
setting it goes to the high risk people
the people with
other underlying conditions as well as
first responders and people working
directly in health care
and so that's going to be done very
rapidly okay thank you
thank you
mr president earlier today dr redfield
confirmed that it looked like november
december the first doses would be able
to be
distributed but then he said that the
vaccine for the general public
likely would not be available until
probably next summer maybe even early
fall
are you comfortable with that time no i
think he made a mistake when he said
that it's just
incorrect information and i called him
and he didn't tell me that and i think
he got the message maybe confused maybe
it was stated incorrectly no we're ready
to go immediately
as the vaccine is announced and it could
be announced in october could be
announced a little bit after
october but uh once we go we're ready
uh as you know fisa is making this
they're taking a tremendous financial
risk and they're spending billions of
dollars on actually
making this vaccine they're in a stage
where they're actually making it
because they feel very confident as to
the results they'll be announcing their
results fairly soon
and no he's uh that's incorrect
information
he was clear in the way yeah well i
think so but i don't think he
means that i don't think he when he said
it
i believe he was confused i'm just
telling you we're ready to go as soon as
the vaccine happens
so when do you want to see it available
what would be a timeline i would say
yeah we will start distributing it
immediately
to the general public very shortly there
i mean it really to the general public
immediately when we go we go we're not
looking to
say gee in six months we're going to
start giving it to the general public no
we want to go immediately no it was an
incorrect statement i saw the statement
i called him i said what did you mean by
that
and i think he just made a mistake
he just made a mistake i think you
misunderstood the question probably
so if you were to put a timeline on when
every person in america
will be able to get a vaccine what would
that be i think it would be
very soon i think our distribution
process is going to go very quickly
i told you we've engaged the military we
have a general who's in charge of all
logistics who
delivers soldiers he's a fantastic guy
he's supposed to be fantastic at what he
does
and we figure that's better than any
company you're going to hire you can't
hire a company like that and
i we look to do distribution immediately
after we get the word that it's good
and i think they're having tremendous
success with the vaccine itself
i think the results will be early and
strong the safety has to be 100
and we're going to insist on that and
obviously the companies are going to
insist on that also
january february what would you think
yeah
the as i said the high priority people
uh will have
sure in some time no later than january
i mean of course it depends on when
things are approved in the emergency
wasn't given i'm talking about this i
can finish
and then it's anticipated there will be
700 million
doses by end of q1 that's 700 million
doses
so by the end of the month that's on the
keyboard dr
ellis do you mind if i ask you q1 yeah
that's the end of march
it's one thing to have the doses but
we've talked to a lot of public health
experts who say if this is happening in
the winter
and you have to socially distance you
can't have the packed lines that we saw
during h1n1
you can't have packed auditoriums you
have to
space it out so that's one thing about
another thing they're worried about
is storing these vaccines and since we
don't know
which one is the winner you know doctors
offices may not have dry ice to handle
negative 80 degrees so these are
challenges are you prepared to
say that you can overcome all those in
three months
yes because uh at least i've been
briefed on the vaccine okay and so
uh all the refrigerators that are
necessary everything is going to be in
place for this
there's a very detailed logistical plan
that was started months ago
and you know you're welcome to read it
on the web but basically yeah
all those things are not a problem
really i mean if people know how to shop
for groceries or go into a store or
sitting
in the restaurants that are open and use
social business and i think they can do
it for vaccines too
and you also have more than one company
you have johnson and johnson you have
pfizer you have
modern or you have others so we could
conceivably have vaccines being given
out by
numerous companies and they're all
world-class companies they're fantastic
companies
that could happen also okay yeah please
go ahead
thank you mr president are you prepared
to sign off on the oracle and tick tock
deal even though the treasury
isn't getting paid and also does the
deal meet your requirements in terms of
national security concerns okay they're
giving me uh
studies on the deal has to be 100 as far
as national security is concerned
and no i'm not prepared to sign off on
anything i have to see the deal
we need security especially after what
we've seen with respect to china and
what's going on
we want security so i'll let you know
they're going to be reporting to me
tomorrow morning
and i will let you know
what about the payments of the treasury
well we're going to see about that uh
amazingly i find that you're not allowed
to do that you're not allowed to accept
money so what kind of a
what kind of a thing is this if they're
willing to make payments to the
government they're not allowed because
there's no
there's no way of doing that from a uh
there's no legal path to doing that i'm
saying wait a minute they're willing to
make a big payment to the government and
we're not allowed to take the money when
does this happen
how foolish can we be so we're gonna
we're looking into that right
now you understand that in other words i
said no i want a big
chunk of that money to go to the united
states government because we made it
possible
and the lawyers come back to me and they
say well there's no way of doing that
you know why because nobody's ever heard
of that before nobody's ever said that
before
nobody's ever said well we'll approve
the deal but we want a lot of money to
go to the government because by
approving the deal we're making the deal
valuable
they've never heard of that before okay
can you believe that right hard to
believe yeah
quick follow-up on tick-tock um you had
said earlier that it was really
important to you that a u.s
company buy tick-tock and according to
the proposals submitted by fight dance
fight dance would keep a majority stake
and oracle would have a minority well
we're going to find out about that
we're looking into that from the
standpoint of bite dance we don't like
that i mean just
conceptually i can tell you i don't like
that
that has not been told to me yet that
has been reported but hasn't been told
to me it could be very accurate
reporting for a change
so if that's the case i'm not going to
be happy with that assuming that bike
dance is china which i think it probably
is yeah
yeah in the back yesterday thank you
president um bill barr
told prosecutors that he wants to charge
violent demonstrators
uh with sedition and you told judge
jeanine that if there's violent
demonstrations on election night
we'll put them down very quickly if they
do that look it's called an insurrection
so i'm wondering why you want to use
that kind of rhetoric when there's such
a well the question was asked me about
if you have violent demonstrations yes
we will put it down very very quickly if
there is
absolutely are you making and i think
the american public wants to see that
yeah oan please oh yeah yeah
thank you mr president um
if there's any kind of demonstration or
violence there will be nothing that
interferes with this project product
this this vote there's going to be
nothing the biggest
problem we have right now are the
ballots
millions of ballots going out that's the
biggest problem when you talk about
other countries whether it's china
russia or many others that get mentioned
they're in a much better position with
these paper ballots
to do something than they would ever be
under the old system
and that's our biggest problem our
biggest threat to this election
is uh governors from opposing parties
controlling ballots
millions of ballots to me that's a much
bigger threat than foreign countries
because much of the stuff coming out
about foreign countries turned out to be
untrue
what is what is true is that many
elections have taken place over the last
year and a half using this ballot system
they've been off by 5 10 15
i think i read one at 40 percent 40
percent
and these are small easy to control
elections
this whole ballot system where you can
send it in
and it's not even requested we're not
talking about it solicited
their unsolicited ballots and they're
sent in
is very dangerous for our country and
you know who knows that better than
anybody
the democrats look at what happened in
manhattan
where they had this kind of an election
and it was so
fraudulent that it should never have
been allowed to be called
we could have 5 10 15 20 off we could
have more than that
the ballots will be stolen who knows
where they're going
who knows where they're coming from it's
not just the counting of the ballots
which by the way which will take forever
it'll take forever you think november
3rd you might not have
i guess at a certain point it goes to
congress you know at a certain point it
goes to congress you know that
this is a disgrace this is being done on
purpose they know it's no good
they know it's it's going to be
fraudulent it's going to be fraud all
over the place
who's getting the ballots who's sending
the ballots
they have people saying you don't need a
verified signature
this is a serious threat to our
democracy and the democrats know that
all we're asking if you solicit the
ballot
you go through a process you ask for a
ballot because you can't be there
uh for a large number of reasons for
whatever
i'm doing it myself i won't be able to
be in florida
you solicit and they send it back you do
it and you send it back that's a process
that you go through
and it's pretty secure i use the word
pretty secure i guess
nothing's foolproof but what's pretty
close to what
the most foolproof thing the thing that
really
uh works is you go to the
ballot box it's going to be very safe i
think by that time covett will be
even lower it's going to be very low
it's going to be a very safe process
we did it during world war one we did it
during world war
ii the biggest threat to this election
is these unsolicited ballots
sent out by the millions controlled by
governors like in nevada who is a
political person very political but far
beyond being governor
where they try to stop you from making a
speech
unsuccessfully but we had to move around
a lot had to move quickly
so this same guy that tried to stop you
from making free speech
outside outside not inside outside they
forced us inside because of what they
did
but outside this is the guy that's
controlling ballots
then you look at pennsylvania you look
at other places
it is a big threat and as far as china
is concerned and russia and
they say north korea they say iran they
say places who knows who knows
but they say all these different places
they can
make forgeries of these ballots they can
do things that
will blow your mind and the democrats
know it's wrong
they know it's going to end up being a
disaster just take a look at what's
happened
take a look at what's happened over the
last year with this same kind of thing
except in a very small setting with very
few ballots going out so that's much
easier
not 53 to 80 million
going out a very small number and you
know what's happened
fraud like you've never seen missing
ballots
ballots that never showed up balance
with bad signatures ballots with no
signatures
and in the case of nevada they don't
even want verification of the signature
it's a disgrace now the hope for our
nation is
it's before judges in pennsylvania it's
before judges in nevada
before judges and other places before
federal judges
and hopefully they'll do what they did
the other day in pennsylvania where we
had a great victory
open up your state it's unconstitutional
to close it
because what they were doing is closing
it and they're closing it for political
reasons
it'll open on november 4th it'll open up
right after the election
but they want people to they want our
numbers to be as bad as possible but the
problem is our numbers are so good with
or without various states opening up
with or without but we had a big legal
victory as you know three days ago
a federal judge told them to open up
their state
it's unconstitutional what you're doing
that's in the case of pennsylvania
now the big cases are going to be the
cases on these
unsolicited ballots and we'll see what
happens right oan please
that the chinese communist party has
been using slave later in xinjiang your
administration has imposed a limited ban
on certain products coming out of
xinjiang stopping short of a full region
ban
um what is your response to the chinese
communist party's
spokespeople who are saying that this is
an outright lie xinjiang does not have
forced labor
and number two have allies expressed
interest in standing
with this administration in taking
action against forced labor
yeah we don't want to see that we've
been very strong on that
we're getting reports and over the next
two three days we'll know very
accurately what the story is and
we'll then take action one way or the
other
yes i just want to ask you about the
wto's recent ruling against the united
states over 200 billion in tariffs on
china should the u.s
remain part of the wto well i have real
questions about it look the u.s
we just won a seven and a half billion
dollar lawsuit
which nobody used to sue before i came
along you know or they used to lose them
every single time now they haven't been
losing them
but we're getting reports on the wto
it's
it's not good never been good to us
the wto as far as i'm concerned was
created to suck
money and jobs out of the united states
to the benefit of china and other
countries that's what
my opinion is whether it was created or
it just turned out to be that way
but the world trade organization has
been
not good for the united states it's been
good for everybody else but it's not
been good
it was uh a method in my opinion of
taking advantage of the united states
so we're looking into what happened and
we'll let we'll get back to you
faster you said you spoke with dr
redfield earlier and you said that he
made a mistake
i think he made a mistake yeah we didn't
i didn't go into any great diff i was
i was very surprised to hear it it
doesn't really matter
here's what doesn't matter we're all set
to distribute immediately
as soon as that vaccine comes out that's
safe and good and works whether it's
fizer johnson
johnson or anybody else we are ready to
distribute it very rapidly as scott said
and as our team knows and they're ready
and that could be on
it could be in october sometime in
october or november
i don't think it's going to be much
later than that but i think it could be
sometime in october
we're ready to move and it'll be a very
full distribution y'all had the call you
said that you told him that he
made a mistake what was his response no
i didn't tell him anything i said what
happened
and i got the impression that he didn't
realize he said what he
might have said i didn't see him say it
but if that's what he said it's a
mistake because he's
so ready we're ready to distribute
immediately
to a vast section of our country and
then beyond
because we want to help other countries
also but we're ready to distribute
immediately that he gave
saying that it wouldn't be ready for the
general public until the middle next
year
sounds very like the one that you kind
of just offered
no no i said that there'll be 700
million doses by end of q1 and everyone
in high risk will have it
we're focused on high risk but we're
going to focus also on general public
very much but we are
our aim is elderly people
and especially elderly people with heart
diabetes problems but we will have it
this is
we're not looking at a small
distribution program we're looking at
distributing to the whole
united states with an immediate focus of
the elderly now under no circumstance
will it be as late as the doctor
said but i think that frankly
if he analyzes you know they hit him
with that question he said that
we are ready at a much faster level
than what he said we will have rapid
distribution
we're set up our military and others are
set up to do it
and we think it could even start taking
place in october but
certainly during november december would
be the latest
because based on what we're hearing
results are
based on what i'm hearing results are
very good so we'll see what happens
you told bob woodward the problem with a
vaccine is a vaccine will take
13 to 14 months once you have it because
you have to test a vaccine
so do you want to well what i was what i
was saying to him no
that was a long time ago when i said
that i didn't we weren't set up at that
time
well how many months ago when was the
statement made you know his book is sort
of obsolete because the book comes
out by the way i read the book last
night very rapidly because it was very
boring
i read it and if you see what i said i
said a lot of really good things i mean
for the most part
people like to turn it around but i said
really good things in that book and as
an example
he doesn't cover i told him what we're
doing in the middle east
and we're doing it in an entirely
different way
and that's not covered in his book the
whole thing isn't covered in his book
and one thing i will say and i respect
the press for this one which is
interesting
almost universally we've been praised
for the deal that we made
yesterday with israel and with you know
two very important
countries in the middle east and uae in
particular where
it's a very powerful group it's a
warrior country it's led by a great
warrior and a
man who's highly respected and if you
take a look at
that and bahrain and israel making a
deal and i will tell you we have at
least four or five
others that want to come in they would
have come in yesterday i talked to two
of them yesterday and they're ready to
trot and uh i think you're gonna have a
whole
level of peace without blood all over
the sand nobody was shot nobody was
killed we killed
hundreds of thousands of people in the
middle east it's all it's been
it's been i always say it's it's uh it's
the bloodiest sand anywhere in
the world and it didn't have to be that
way the single worst decision
our country ever made was to go into the
middle east
not only the millions of people killed
and i include people on both sides you
know some people say oh you shouldn't
say that i said i'll say it
on both sides such a horrible thing was
done such a horrible mistake was made
we're doing this a different way so we
have those two countries we have
at least five that we're negotiating
with right now and you know you can only
negotiate with so many i think they're
all going to come in
uh i think ultimately uh the
palestinians are going to come in these
are all the people that are funding them
you know i stopped funding the
palestinians
fairly early on because they were saying
bad things about our country i said we
mean we're giving them
750 million dollars a year and they're
saying all bad things about our country
so i stopped funding them very early on
but they get funded by other very rich
countries to them it's like
a spec it's nothing but they get funded
and uh but i think now that these
countries these very rich countries
are uh part of the deal and they're
gonna you'll see
over the next fairly short period of
time other countries will come in
i think saudi arabia ultimately will
come in too
i think getting saudi arabia will be
great but i think saudi arabia is my
feeling
it's not based on knowledge other than a
couple of conversations
i had with the king but saudi arabia i
think will be coming in too
and you'll end up in with peace in the
middle east and nobody thought it could
be done
and nobody thought it could be done this
way i went to some very smart people i
went to some
people in the middle east and they said
you'll never be able to do it it's not
possible to make peace well
now they're saying to me nobody ever
thought of doing this
they all thought you make the deal first
with the palestinians it had to be that
way
and i will say the resistance was some
countries didn't want to do it unless
the palestinians were there first that
was just a psychological thing more than
anything else but they were wrong
those guys the people our
uh great representatives that have been
doing this for 35 years that were
telling me how to do it
but they all failed they were in
clinton's administration they were in
bush
they were in uh obama
all these great brilliant people they're
all telling me how to do it and i said
they're wrong and i guess i was right
and and when you see let me just well
let's talk finish this
when you see the countries that will be
coming a very short period of time not
talking in a long period of time
all of the countries that will be coming
in just like you saw bahrain yesterday
and
uae and i can think of
i mean at least five that are going to
be quick and easy others will be
quick and easy also once the five comes
come in
so you're going to have something you're
going to peace in the middle east and
we want to get out you know we want to
our soldiers are largely coming home i
said
the endless wars the ridiculous endless
wars and i will say this
if i didn't withdraw our country from
that horrible
iran nuclear deal that horrible stupid
deal
where president obama paid 150 billion
dollars for nothing and gave 1.8
billion dollars in cash 1.8 billion you
know what that is
1.8 billion in cash that's more
impressive than 150 billion
paid normally but he gave all this money
all of this all of these chips that we
had we had these chips and he gave them
all away
and we got nothing and you know it was a
short-term deal it would be practically
expiring now
we practically it starts to expire
actually right now but it would
practically be
and there is no way we will let iran
have a nuclear weapon just remember
that there's no way that's going to
happen
just like this but do you want to
reverse what you told woodward about the
13 to 14 month
timeline for a vaccine well the vaccine
at the time i
thought it might take that period of
time but we've stepped it up very
substantially and now i mean i'm just
telling you
this is just what it is we've been able
to step it up very very rapidly
i never thought we could have a vaccine
as quickly as we did but i freed it up i
freed up the fda
dr hahn's done a great job and they're
ready to approve something when they
come in
the other thing that's happening that's
very different is you look at a company
like fisa
great company really one of the great
companies of the world johnson and
johnson they're all
great companies they're doing a lot of
testing at a very rapid rate that
nobody's ever seen anything like it you
know they're out in third
they're in the third level of trial and
i think that you're going to see things
that are amazing
when i made statements like that that's
an old statement
when i made statements like that i had
no idea that we could produce as well as
we're producing
but only because of what i've done with
the fda and other things
can we come up with numbers like that
we're lucky that we don't have to
because that was considered fast if this
were a
an administration from the past and i
think i can say
far beyond obama it was other
administrations also
you wouldn't have a vaccine for two and
a half three years and we're going to
have a vaccine within
at most a couple of months okay
mr president if i could ask you about
coronavirus relief do you support the
problem
solvers caucus proposal that was put
forward
are you comfortable with the file
something like gold something like that
yeah i like the larger amount i've said
that you know some of the republicans
disagree but i think i can convince them
to go along with that because i like the
larger number
uh i want to see people get money i want
to see it wasn't their fault that this
happened it was china's fault you know
people say oh maybe you shouldn't say
that that's not nice it was china's
fault
so i'd like to see the larger number
yeah i would like to see it
there are some things i disagree with
but i'm sure they can be negotiating
now i heard nancy pelosi said she
doesn't want to leave until we have an
agreement she's come a long way that's
great
if she said that she's come a long way
i agree with her we should have an
agreement people should be
helped and they should be helped as
rapidly as possible
and i think it's going to happen i think
it's very important
so the problem solvers came up with it's
a group of people
in congress as you know you know them
all i know them all they're very good
people i guess you'd consider them dead
center
but in many cases they're not they're
left there right but they came up with
this idea
and i think they're well on their way to
suggesting some pretty good things yeah
i agree with a lot of it in terms of
things that you don't agree are you
comfortable with the 500 i think
the things i don't agree we can probably
negotiate but i think we've made some
progress over the last week
and i think it was positive that they
came out with that report
would you endorse that proposal well not
that a proposal but we're getting closer
we're getting closer i do like a lot of
money getting sent to people
that really were really were hurt
unnecessarily by china because they
could have stopped it they stopped it
from going into their country
they could have stopped it from coming
to our country and from going to europe
and from going to
the rest of the world 188 different
countries from all over the world please
president uh the director of the cdc
also testified today that
a mass in his estimation is guaranteed
to protect
the american public more from the
chronovirus than a vaccine
you have as detailed poured a lot of
resources into a vaccine development why
not devote drugs and domestics
why not devote your energy now to a
campaign to have all americans wear a
mask something that if
if more effective than a vaccine would
also help schools in the economy number
one is not more effective
by any means than a vaccine and i called
him about that those were the two things
i discussed with him
and i believe that uh if you ask him
he would probably say that he didn't
understand the question
because i said to mason those two
questions the one question which we
covered in the math question
and uh and i was inaccurately covered
because i was on with george
last night george stephanopoulos and uh
i enjoyed it i think people enjoyed it i
got
you know a lot of people said very good
things about the show i hope they did
well
but they said a lot of good things about
the show but they always cut my
sentences off you know they cut it off
on masks and masks have problems too and
i talked about
the masks have to be handled very gently
very carefully
uh i see that in restaurants they're
people with masks and they're playing
around with their mask and they have it
their fingers are in their mask and then
they're serving with plates i mean i
think there's a lot of
problems with masks no vaccine is much
more effective than the max
and if we get the vaccine we have uh
added to the fact that our numbers are
going way down you know you see the
numbers i'm just reading you statistics
that are
from wherever they get them but they're
very highly
qualified statistics but no the mask is
not as important as the vaccine the va
the mask perhaps helps don't forget a
lot of people didn't like the concept of
masks initially dr fauci didn't like him
and a lot of people didn't and i'm not
knocking anybody because i understand
both
sides of the argument but when i called
up
robert today i said to him what's with
the mask he said
i think i answered that question
incorrectly i think maybe he had
misunderstood it i mean you know you
have two
questions maybe he misunderstood both of
them but the
answer to the one is it's going to be a
much faster distribution than he said
maybe he's not aware of the distribution
process it's not really his thing as
much as it would be let's say mine
but the distribution is going to be much
faster as far as the mask is concerned
i hope that the vaccine's going to be a
lot more beneficial than the masks
because people have used the masks
but when i looked at that chart that we
put up if you look
you know we're right if you do the good
job they had i guess 240 000
but if you do the good if it worked out
well now look
one death is too much one death is too
much should have never happened
but the lower level was at that 240 000
between 100 and something and 240 000.
as far as the mask is concerned he made
a mistake
i mean perhaps they are part of the role
for the decrease in cases that
because they are affected as you just
said so i know you've warned no they may
be effective
and i wear them when i'm in a hospital
or when i'm in a setting with a lot of
questions
why not we're more often i have the
white house staff where more often just
set an example for the country
well i'm tested and i'm sometimes
surprised when i see somebody sitting
and like
with joe joe feels very safe in a mask i
don't know maybe he doesn't want to
expose
his face i don't know what's going on
he'll be way away from people
nowhere near people there'll be nobody
with him he doesn't draw any crowds so
have circles these big circles they'll
be way far away
there's no reason for him to have masks
on we get tested i'm tested i have
people tested when people come into the
oval office it's like a big deal
no matter who they are the heads of
countries they all get tested
so i'm in sort of a different position
and maybe if i wasn't in that position
i'd be wearing it
more but i've worn masks and especially
i like to wear them when i'm in hospital
not for me so much as for other people
okay
mr president can i just ask you about
some questions mr president
one of our doctor outlets um dr atlas
you mentioned
uh minorities would be the first focus
of the distribution
how would that exactly work in practice
when it's being distributed specifically
to minorities
and the second week he says minorities
and senior citizens yes
can you talk us through a bit more on
the focus on distributing to
minorities and how that would work and
then for you mr president
uh you mentioned the drop in the poverty
rate specifically we noticed that just
the news that the poverty rate for
african-americans hit historic lows
that the household wealth increased
historically for african americans
what was driving that increase in wealth
for african americans and now in 2020
with the virus with unemployment spiking
what would be your plan for the second
term to improve lives well i'll go first
because your question i appreciate your
question and yeah we've had a tremendous
drop in poverty
for all people in our nation but
in particular for african americans and
that statistic came in and it's because
the african-american community the black
community has had
the lowest the best employment numbers
that we've ever had both employment and
unemployment depending on how you want
to define it
but we've had the best employment
numbers we've ever had now we had the
greatest
employment in the country ever almost
160 million people we've never been
close to that number but we were just
six months ago and uh yeah the
i'm very proud of the numbers african
americans hispanic americans they had
the best numbers they've ever had by far
both employment and unemployment
depending on definition
uh thank you very much for that question
scott do you want to answer that
uh so what i to clarify said that the
first prioritization
is the high-risk people and front-line
healthcare workers
uh but just to reiterate what i said
there are 51 000
outlets for for uh distribution for for
vaccination
and there's over 14 000 federally
qualified health centers that are
particularly targeted to minority and
low income
areas so that that's a focus i want to
point out two other things
we're also prioritizing testing to
historically black colleges and
universities
and we're in the process of getting that
finalized because we know that there's
high
higher morbidity within certain ethnic
groups
and the last thing i would say is uh
it's particularly heinous
and egregious abuse of the media to
instill fear
into people about taking a vaccine
because there is no shortcut here
everything is safe everything is
effective and for people who are
particularly an influence
on minority communities to instill fear
and doubt there's a particularly
you know outrageous abuse of public
policy
of leadership these are people that have
higher risk
and so i implore everyone's in high risk
category that when we get a safe
effective vaccine
they should take the vaccine i will say
this is a phenomena that only happened
when they realized that we may very well
have
the vaccine prior to a certain very
important date
namely november 3rd once they heard that
the democrats started
just to show you how bad the intention
is they started knocking the vaccine
had nothing to do with the vaccine it
was totally made up it's all
disinformation
just like they put an ad in about
football just like they put
with respect to me i'm the one that got
football back and i was always against
him
going out it was ridiculous that big ten
and now hopefully pac-10 goes back and i
say that
uh just like even worse they put out a
totally
fake ad totally made-up story it's a
made-up story by a third-rate magazine
where the head guy i guess the head
person
i have no idea who he is i don't know
but he's friends with obama and clinton
so they made up this horrible story and
then they did ads well they made up this
story too
this story is very simple they started
knocking the vaccine
as soon as they heard that this actually
may come out prior to election
now it may or may not but it'll be
within a matter of weeks
it'll be within a matter of weeks from
november it's ready to go and it's ready
to
for massive distribution to everybody
with a focus again on
seniors and i will say also the
historically
black colleges and universities we
are doing at my suggestion because they
have had
a difficult problem there we are doing
more testing there and
uh finer testing we have our our great
apparatus there
but we when you look at what we've done
on testing in terms of the technology
and the amount it's been
really amazing in fact i think we're
going to crack 100 million tests very
soon in the very near future we're going
to be cracking 100 million tests
now what that does do is it shows up
more cases if we didn't test we wouldn't
have cases you would have no cases other
countries they don't test they don't
have cases
and then they say oh the united states
well but we're proud of it because it
shows
where there may be a problem and it
helps people but we're doing
tremendous testing at the historically
black
colleges and universities and that was a
suggestion i made and i think it's a
good
i think it's a good suggestion yeah
please go ahead yes
thank you um uh the core of vice
president biden's argument
is that you don't trust the scientists
you don't listen to them
and here up on the podium today you're
twice contradicting
the director of your own cdc on the
science who testified before congress
today
no he's contradicting himself i think he
misunderstood the question well he was
testifying
you know what i think i think he
misunderstood i told you i don't have to
go through this
i think he misunderstood the questions
but i'm telling you here's the bottom
line distribution is going to be very
rapid he may not know that maybe he's
not aware of that and maybe he's not
dealing with the military etc like i do
distribution is going to be very rapid
and the vaccine's going to be
very powerful it's going to solve a
tremendous problem
it's going to be very powerful the
american people trust you
on the pandemic when you're
contradicting the head of the cdc and
because of the great job we've done
because of the great things we've done
in other fields also
because of the fact that we created
ventilators we built ventilators by the
thousands and now we're supplying to the
world
because of all of the incredible work
we've done for governors
who are on every call saying this is
incredible this is great this is great
sometimes they're not quite as friendly
at a news conference when you have
people covering it but we have done a
phenomenal job on covet 19 as they like
to call it
i call it other things but we have done
a phenomenal job
i get calls from other people in other
countries they can't believe the job
we've done
and then they'll say is there any way
that you could get us ventilators i say
how many do you need 1 000 ventilators
i said we'll be able to take care of it
we're making thousands of ventilators
very complex very expensive
very difficult thing to make we're
making thousands a month
the cupboard was bare when i got here
and
i will tell you our distribution is
going to be very rapid and very
it's going to be all-encompassing we are
going to have a focus on certain groups
that have
problems senior citizens etc but it's a
very powerful it's a it's going to be a
very powerful distribution
it's going to cover everybody and it's
going to cover them rapidly i don't know
whether or not the doctor
knows that how much he covers but i
called him because i said
why did you say that long he wasn't that
aware of it and the other one was the
mask
the vaccine is going to have tremendous
power it's going to be extremely strong
it's going to be extremely successful
we're not going to have a problem and
the mask may help
and i hope it helps and i think it
probably does
but again the mask is a mixed bag there
are some people
professionals scott you would know a lot
of them but there are some people that
don't like the mask because of the
touchiness and the touching and then
you're touching everything else
they have they feel that masks have
problems so anyway go ahead in the
background
mr president mr president do you have
confidence in doctors
yeah i do i do i do well he gave you
some answers questions
uh he sort of i think maybe
misunderstood a question
but we're beyond that now we're really
in final stages of
vaccines we're getting ready to go phase
one on distribution
and i think it might come out even
sooner than you think
uh i think the vaccine's going to be
even better than people thought
originally i think people
uh are going to be really surprised at
the success of the vaccine i think it's
going to be a tremendous success
and we're fighting a very powerful party
with a poor candidate in my opinion but
we're fighting a very
very powerful party and they're partners
with the
media and because they're working
together very closely
and they only started hitting on the
vaccine when they hit on the vaccine
they only hit on it when they realized
that wow
this is amazing they may have it even
before the election all of a sudden they
didn't like the vaccine so much
thank you so much mr president why are
you informed about
positive coronavirus cases i cannot hear
you themselves were you informed about
coronavirus cases positive cases
in the white house today about today
yes on your staff on your establishment
reports of white house staff members
testing
about staff you may have done it i heard
about it this morning
at a very small level yes i heard about
it this morning i
i don't know we can have a report to you
if you feel it's necessary but it's a
small
it's last night i heard about it for the
first time and it's a small number of
cases maybe it's not even cases do you
know do you have any idea if there's
yes we're not going to confirm the
identities yeah that's okay
yes but um it did not affect the event
and press was not around
uh and it's not anybody that was near me
uh from what i heard a very small number
i think you can probably give the number
out later on when you find out what it
might be
one person it was one person okay
it was one person that's i mean so not
too much
not a person that i was associated with
thank you very much everybody
thank you thank you very much
you